تشير تقديرات المخابرات الأمريكية إلى أن 80
بالمائة من مقاتلي مجموعة فاغنر حتى
أواخر العام الماضي لقوا مصرعهم أو جرحوا
ثمانين بالمائة ، لكن يبدو أن
الروس يفضلون كثيرًا خلافاتهم في القتال
مع فاغنر على الخطوط الأمامية
والقتال مع الجيش الروسي السابق ،
إليك مقطع فيديو جديد.
وجدنا جنود بوتين بشكل صحيح ،
لذا فهم جنود في
الجيش الروسي وهم الآن يناشدون
مجموعة فاجنر للسماح لهم بالخروج من
الجيش والانضمام إلى الجيش الخاص
بدلاً من ذلك ، هنا
الوضع هنا أدى إلى
حل  من فوجنا نطلب
السماح لنا بالانضمام إلى رتبك ،
فهناك 10 منا هنا مستعدون للقتال.
إنهم يخدمون البلد الذي
يخدمونه لرغبتهم في القتال من أجل
فاجنر ، هذه الكلمات تلعن
لجنرالات بوتين ، وبالنسبة لبوتين نفسه
في الواقع ، اعترف بوتين اليوم بخسائره
ولم تقل أبدًا أن
وكالة الاستخبارات السرية الخاصة به ،
FSB على وجه التحديد ، عانت من
خسائر بسبب  عن الحرب ، لذا فهو لا
يتحدث حتى عن الجنود بل يتحدث
عن FSB ، بل يقول إن الوحدة التي
تكبدت خسائر كانت متورطة بشكل مباشر
في اقتباسه لعملية عسكرية خاصة
تحارب بنشاط الإرهاب والجريمة المنظمة
والفساد والتطرف كما
أسماها يتحدث عن الموت في صفوفهم